and he said houston i do love it it is
exactly what i'm looking for is this
exactly what we need but the fact of the
matter is i am not going to take
something to my boss that's not based on
a book because i don't want to put my
job on the line for you
that's exactly what it told me
why don't we see new ideas in hollywood
i think it's because of risk i think
when
you look at the risk analysis of
feature films or or television
the
there's a hesitancy
of
taking a chance on a new idea you have
to you have to
think about hollywood as
not in a vacuum where
there's all these middle managers in
hollywood they're all executives right
and uh there's there's there's a hundred
people that that are all involved in
everything in the decision of what to
make and what not to make uh and and by
and large
people don't make those decisions based
on what is the what's going to propel
the industry forward creatively and
what's going to be you know that what
what does the artistic integrity of the
of the uh industry need and like they're
not asking those questions they're
asking the questions of
what can i do not to get fired from my
job
and uh you know if it's a lot easier for
these executives
to
say no to something
that could potentially be risky than to
say
yes to something that could be
potentially risky and it not work out
and all of a sudden they get the blame
uh because they took the risk i mean if
if i'm if if i'm a studio executive and
i have two scripts in front of me and
one is this really hip interesting
progressive edgy you know uh uh script
that really pushes boundaries in a
really interesting way uh that's a lot
of creative uh uh
edgy interesting things and then i have
the reboot of the brady bunch as a
feature film
uh starring vince vaughn as greg brady
which actually sounds sounds kind of
good but the uh but if i have that in
front of me and it's like solidly
mediocre right uh but um if i have those
two things in front of me the most
artistically interesting choice the new
is the new idea let's let's promote new
ideas let's not go back to the well in
the brady bunch right um but
99 times out of 100 what's going to
happen is going to be we're going to
make the brady bunch not because we
think the brady bunch is going to be
better or
one it has pre-awareness in the market
right so it has a community of people
that already know what the brady bunch
is even if you don't haven't seen an
episode of the brady bunch
odds are people have heard of the brady
bunch and so there's this market
awareness that that shifts the risk and
they think it's a safer bet and because
it's the safer bet they think if i push
my chips in on the brady bunch and it
gets made
and it doesn't do as well as we think
i still be able to keep my job
because i made the safe decision but if
i go all in on on a completely original
idea
that that is the more artistically
interesting idea and it doesn't work
guess what who's on the chopping block
me for making the bad call
right and listen it may not be my fault
maybe other people's fault but you know
everybody's kind of shifting the blame
everybody wants to blame somebody in in
and
and especially on the executive level
you know it it's you could only lose 50
million dollars to somebody else's money
so many times before they don't give you
50 million dollars to lose anymore right
and so it's tough uh that decision to
green lighter not the green light but
that's not made in a vacuum they they
sit there and say how do i
you know how do i keep my nice
six-figure salary with my premium health
insurance and how do i keep my kids in
private school and how do i keep my wife
not having to work and do the things
that she likes to do and how do i keep
my house and my gated community and how
do i keep you know the the two cars that
i have and uh like what are the
decisions
that can preserve that
and
i'm gonna do those
because then if i do those long enough
eventually my boss will retire and maybe
i get it promoted and then and then
becomes that game and listen i'm not
even criticizing those people for doing
that maybe i do that in the same if i'm
in the same situation i have kids i got
a house i got a wife like i got dogs i
got things right so and i don't want to
get fired we need health insurance like
there's all these other pressures that
come in uh but but if you if you now if
you now look at the entire industry as
an industry
that is motivated
not on artistic integrity but how do i
keep my job
that really clues you in of why we don't
see a lot of new stuff that's why we see
reboots that's and listen largely
reboots don't work we saw that with
female ghostbusters we saw that with the
new terminator movie we saw that you
know we've seen that every now and then
they work right hawaii five-o worked i
think uh uh there you know there's some
that that
21 drip street i think worked uh
actually the times you actually see it
work i think it's when you shift
platform if if it was originally a movie
then they turn it into a tv show or
originally a tv show and they turn it
into a film that usually works more than
film the film or
show to show typically just as an
anecdotal observation
but it's uh
largely reboots don't
work that well in the industry just look
at the numbers
so why do they do it it's because it's
the safer bet
even though we know it's not a safe bet
it looks like the safer bet so when
people come to blame
somebody i can say well no everybody
knew the brady bunch it's not my fault
it's vince vaughn's fault it's the
director's fault somebody else's fault
but mine right so then i get a stay in
my gated community i mean it's really
interesting i mean look the the
executives i was i was talking to the uh
with
the um the president of he had a really
interesting comment he said you know
executives they
they live in the gated communities
and then they
leave their gated communities and drive
through the gate into the lot
and then work and then they drive back
to their gated communities and never go
east of robertson right and they live in
this weird little bubble that
breeds
a different mentality than you know than
the consumer or the audience or you know
when we're saying why don't we have any
more ideas
it's not our money on the line right
it's easy to say there should be new
ideas we shouldn't make so many
superhero movies it's not our money
like it's easy it's easy to say that if
you're not if it's if it was your 50
million or 100 million dollars that
you're actually
putting on the line
maybe that conversation changes right
because now you're like maybe i don't
want to take the risk on the
progressively interesting edgy
psychological thriller that doesn't have
any pre-awareness in the market maybe it
will end up being one of the coolest
most artistic films that we've seen in
the last 10 years but we've all seen
movies like that not be financial
successes this is when this is how they
turn in the cult classics right and and
we see movies and we're like how did
that how did that not work why does
everybody see this and there's there's a
hundred reasons why a thousand reasons
why great films aren't commercial
successes and not being a commercial
success doesn't
not make you a great film artistically
of course right uh but when it's your
money on the line
it's a different story right and so and
so you have to and if and when it's your
job on the line when you're spending
somebody else's when it's your job to
spend someone else's money which puts
your job on the line the calculation
changes right i think it's that's a you
know i i had i had a situation where i
pitched a i pitched a tv show to a
studio and uh they were looking for
content for their their digital
extension of their of their network and
they they told me what they were looking
for i pitched this idea the the the uh
to a producer had a had a pod deal uh
with the network and he said
this is perfect i love it this is
exactly what we're looking for and i'm
super excited because i think oh well
this this deal's done this is great and
he said
what what book is this based off of
and i said oh it's not based off a book
it's an original idea
and his whole body language changed he
like slumped down and says oh
yeah it needs to be based on a book
and i and i said
no it doesn't because you love it and
you think it's perfect
and it's exactly what you need so we're
good right
he said no needs to be based on a book
so
is it possible
that we could find a book that already
exists
that
is kind of like the idea we can option
that book and then say this idea is
based on that book
and i said that's this is the stupidest
conversation i've ever had with anybody
in my whole life you said it's perfect
you said it's exactly what you're
looking for you love it what's the
problem and he said houston i do love it
it is exactly what i'm looking for is
this exactly what we need but the fact
of the matter is i am not going to take
something to my boss that's not based on
a book because i don't want to put my
job on the line for you
that's exactly what it told me
and i said i appreciate your honesty i
really honestly did like appreciate like
that insight i got it
i expected this guy
to go out on a on a limb stick his neck
out
for
an idea and an ip that that wasn't
established in the marketplace didn't
have any community built around it
didn't have any market presence it was
risky and i expected him to assume my
risk which puts his job on the line and
and he didn't what he didn't feel
comfortable with that because he wanted
to he didn't care about the art
i'm gonna say he didn't care about the
art
he didn't just care about the art i mean
of course he wanted to make a good show
right but there was other considerations
that were very practical
he wanted to keep his job
and we forget that we we forget that
that in the music industry the a r
executives you know that there's a lot
of undiscovered talent that may be
better than other people but but all of
a sudden
i'm gonna sign the tick tock star that
is much worse than this undiscovered
talent because the tick tock star has 12
million people that follow the tick tock
talk star on tick tock
therefore if the tick tock star washes
out
it's not my fault because i took the
safe bet rather than i go out and pluck
the undiscovered dude from iowa that
doesn't have any following he washes out
guess what it's on me because i took the
risk i didn't i i took a risk and i lost
and and so the calculation changes then
this is why this is why uh somebody like
like jake paul or logan paul they they
can go out and they can they can fight
uh uh these these these named boxers
they can go out and fight floyd
mayweather i mean did logan paul fight
floyd mayweather because he's the the
best most deserving boxer in the world
no
he did it like he was able to do that
because it was a safe bet like he had
pre-awareness in the market and then
just made sense and so like it just you
know that's just the the the fact of the
matter of it right like it's just jake
paul
can go
and write a script and sell that script
to a major studio faster than 99
of independent screenwriters in
hollywood right now that are
19 000 times more talented than jake
paul
no offense to jake paul he may be a
closet screenwriter i'm not sure i don't
think he is but but you get what i'm
saying is is
it's not because he's better it's
because he's safer and and the
executives know that the executives know
that and and they can they don't think
that jake paul will write better stuff
but they think if they bet on jake paul
rather than you
if jake paul doesn't work they can keep
their jobs so we always as creators as
filmmakers we always have to understand
the business of the business and
understand the very human calculation
that is going on
in the executive level or the investment
level or the people that are behind the
desk
it's not these decisions aren't made in
a vacuum it's not just what's going to
make the best movie unfortunately that's
not the case anymore right maybe maybe
it was back in
1977 maybe it was a different mentality
that went into executives but today's
executives it's a high-stakes
high-pressure environment and and
there's there's real careers
on the line there's real families that
rely on real salaries and
and
we just think
we just think well as long as our
concept's right and as long as our
three-act structure works and as long as
our character development's right then
if if if i if i am able to execute the
art the right way
then then they should make my idea and
uh just it's just and then you get
frustrated when they don't and then you
see crappy movies that are released that
are reboots and you're like oh where's
the original ideas
just a more complicated
very human calculation that's going on
that's different than the calculation
you think is going on
well and people are voting with their
dollars
someone's seeing it whether they're the
ones that are also leaving a gated
community to go into the gated you know
parking lot at the local cineplex
someone's buying these tickets
and so
i i you know whether they whether they
just are checking their phone the entire
time
or not and they're not really they're
just going to appease their their kids
or their friends
is to not to be known right now but but
so someone is seeing these things sure
that's the hard part and and the ones
that these art house films or the these
very unique edgy indie dramas whatever
um
unfortunately they
they're they're
people aren't always voting with their
dollars to show that they love that
stuff sure and and listen and you're
right the market decides the market
decides what it likes and what it isn't
like and uh yeah and and
that's the way normal business works
that's the way the world works the
market decides what works and what does
it and we can't just sit back and make
value judgments and say well my my movie
was better than that well
if the market has decided that it's not
now artistically speaking you know
that's maybe a different consideration
this is this is the the difference
between the oscars
and
the people's choice awards or the just
look at the box office like really i
mean they don't give out the oscars just
based the best picture could be what was
the highest uh achieving box office
picture of the year they don't do that
they look at they look at the art and
there's artistic achievement that's the
focus of the oscars but really the the
the
the red the regular
the regular audience member you know
again i'm from kentucky we i don't you
know i'm not from the coast and uh now
that i've been on the coast for 15 years
i realized you said it's a different
mentality when you're in hollywood
you know people seen all the oscar
movies and they've seen all the all the
the streaming shows and all the deep
cuts and they can you know but you go
you go to middle america you go to
wyoming you go to kentucky you go to
ohio go to georgia
it's it's it's there you know people
don't people don't know the directors
they don't know the dps and they don't
know you know all the the deep cut indie
films and they haven't seen you know
david lynch's third movie he made out of
film school and like they they like that
but but when you live
in the bubble of hollywood maybe new
york right you convince yourself that
everybody thinks this way and and you
start making
you start making stuff for people in the
bubble
right listen not saying that you just
have to make
you know so the quote-unquote studio
crap you know the quote-unquote big
commercial high concept film you have to
make superheroes all the time there
there are there is room for
art
but
but i think ultimately
you need to figure out how to marry art
and commerciality that's the there's an
intersection that can happen and when
that happens that's that's magic i i i i
it it never
never ceases to surprise me of how many
filmmakers fight for the right to be a
starving artist
and uh they they they find pride in it
and uh i just i i
can never understand it i would much
rather than be well-fed artist still be
an artist
but figure out how to operate in a
commercial environment where the
audience will vote with their dollars i
feel like we have to find that
intersection you know something like a
quiet place was was i think in a good
example of that it was i thought it was
a very well made interesting artistic
very very different choice of of how to
do a monster movie and very almost risky
in a way
but it had commercial sensibility and it
worked and you look at something like
ted lasso i think you know ted lasso i i
feel like is is is a really interesting
commercial success that isn't
game of thrones right like it but at the
same time isn't the office or like i
feel like this it's an interesting it's
an interesting thing if you look at
what's going on in the emmys you know uh
the people that are cleaning up the
enemies it was you know the crown and uh
the uh uh you know queen's gambit right
the queen gambit was a huge commercial
success
but at the same time i think was a a
wild artistic success as well i feel
like it fit that intersection and i feel
like that's
what a lot of independent filmmakers
struggle with uh is finding that
intersection uh but uh because they they
you know
they need to they need to think outside
the bubble um and listen ultimately you
got you got to make what's in your heart
and make what drives you and and
sustained you right and so uh um but
it's you know it becomes difficult when
you're making stuff that
that uh that the market doesn't bear
right and if you're and if you're happy
with that and you're fine with that
muscle top that's great but uh but
ultimately i feel like we need to figure
out that intersection and if you can
again it goes back to that pre-awareness
conversation if you can figure out how
to take that
interesting super artistic
you know edgy
ip
if that people don't want to touch
because it's it's too risky
if you're able to establish that in the
market in three or four different ways
or even one way like you establish as a
podcast and it pops to the podcast and
now a hundred thousand people subscribe
to that podcast guess what
it's the same edgy progressive artistic
character drama idea but now all of a
sudden the studios are going to now be
more apt to take a a
take a gamble on that original idea
because you were able to establish in
the marketplace first right so i think
you know that approach really
really benefits people that don't just
want to make superhero movies or marvel
movies or zombie movies or vampire
movies or whatever you know the big
genre flicks or whatever it is they want
to do some different
artistic interesting things
even more these people have to embrace
all the tools in the toolbox they have
to figure out how to establish in the
marketplace let's let's prove the
audience and once we can prove the
audience then all of a sudden these
people that were that were nervous about
taking taking a flyer on it are are
going to be a lot less nervous because
they see that you've proven yourself in
the marketplace i had an investor that
said that that told me every single
uh movie that is pitched to him uh he he
he has the filmmakers go
he said he'll he'll invest if he decides
to invest he will only invest 80
and it's 80 finishing funds and he makes
the filmmakers go and raise 20 the first
of the budget on kickstarter
right and and it's it's one i think he's
tested on the horsepower of the
filmmaker but really what he's looking
for is you need to prove that there's a
market you need to prove to me that
there are people that will actually get
behind this thing and if there's people
that actually get behind this thing
guess what okay cool i'll come up with
the the other eighty percent but you
gotta you gotta generate the market
first right and so uh so i think
if you are one of the filmmakers that
have the
edgier
non-commercial idea
then you have to figure out a way to get
that story and that ip to as many people
as you can aggregate the data and the
analytics of the audience and then use
that to soften the risk analysis that
was was was probably well against you
that was working against you but now you
can shift that
now to potentially depending on the
success to actually working for you in a
great way
and and two with with the queen's gambit
as as sort of edgy and artistic as it
was walter tevis had already proven
himself with the hustler sure and and
and then it's the man who fell from
earth
and i'm not sure how all that fared but
so there were there was a succession of
of
of successes i guess you could call it
and so
if if it had just been an obscure
screenwriter who wrote the exact same
thing sure would they have taken a
chance on it as amazing as it was well
this is this is what they tell you when
you go when you go shop shop a a script
that's non unbranded content right uh
they'll say um
they'll say you need to go package this
you need to find attachments to this and
you need to go find an actor that will
say i'll act in this or you need to find
a director that says i'll direct as a
producer that says i'll produce this and
if you get the attachments
involved now all of a sudden they may
take a chance on an original idea that's
unbranded that's not based on anything
else because
they're getting the pre-awareness from
the talent
rather than the ip
right so uh and so yeah if you can get
you know if you can get uh
julia roberts to say hey i'm in or get
michael b jordan said i'll i'll i'll be
in that that'd be great or you know you
get uh you know uh
the rock to say i'll i'll i'll produce
it and star in it right if you can get
that
then the game changes for you
the problem with that the practical
problem with that is it's difficult to
get attachments it's hard you know talk
to any agents and and like you know the
agents will tell you they'll say you
know uh that their clients have scripts
they're the the people they rep they
have a stack of script that's taller
than my seven-year-old that they're
waiting for them to read to decide what
to attach to yeah and then that's the
ones that actually get to them
right
but it's how do you get to these people
right how do you how do you like for the
for the the mere mortal filmmaker
how do you get to michael b jordan how
do you get your script to michael b
jordan especially if you're unrep now if
you're if you have a manager or an agent
then then you expect your agent to
figure out how to connect with their
agent and make the submission and things
like that but especially if you're if if
you're unwrapped it's like it's it's in
your impossibility unless you you know
seem at a club and you know you get in
the conversation or or you know your
your sister is friends with his cousin
and you know one of those weird gotta
know people to know people type of thing
right that hollywood
works you know with
a lot of ways but it's hard to get those
attachments i had a a buddy who is a
professional house sitter for
celebrities when they go out of town
like he's licensed and bonded as a as a
as a house sitter uh which is you know
god bless america that that can even be
a thing uh but but so he goes out and
you know he uh um
uh uh these celebrities go to town he'll
stay at their house feed their dogs feed
their parent things like that and then
uh and then you know there's somebody
there in case they get robbed or you
know
they think they won't get robbed if
somebody's in the house so but he was
telling me that he was at uh he was he
was staying at um
that at a at an actor's house who
was an a-list actor in the 70s late 70s
um
now is older probably a c-list actor you
know at this point not you know doesn't
do a lot of stuff uh but used to be you
know everybody knows him his big name
right uh and he and he told me he said
he would receive courier packages of
scripts and he would open them up take
the script out open up a room and throw
it in and there was this huge pile of
scripts there that this guy was supposed
to be reading through in order to decide
what to attach to
what's going to be your next movie right
and and it's just like
so frustrating for writers and and
because we're writing this stuff and we
send it out and we just we we're we we
think okay the rock's gonna read this
and i'm just waiting for the rock to get
back to me and tom hanks is gonna you
know maybe be in my movie maybe not
right but at the same but now you know
it's it's
150 scripts
before he'll get to your script and who
knows when that is it's a hard game to
get attachments right if you can get
attachments great but but
i like to now say
i'm gonna i'm gonna now approach
ip in a way that um
that
i'm going to presume i don't get any
bigger attachments i'm not going to i'm
not going to not try to get attachments
of course you attempt to get attachments
but i'm going to presume i don't and so
that if i do it's gravy it's not the
entree i'm not betting on it right and
so i'm going to try to attack the market
and build the ip with pre-awareness as
much as i can
with the mindset that i'll never get
attachments so that i can skew the risk
analysis myself through the congress the
aggregation of the of the audience and
then if
jennifer lawrence decides to be in the
movie then
even better it's gravy right it's it's
the icing on the cake not the cake
itself right but but that shows you the
pre-awareness has to come from somewhere
it's either coming from the talent or
it's either coming from the ip but it
has to come from somewhere right unless
this is this is my eternal caveat to
that horror movies horror movies are
this really bizarre exception somebody
like jason blum can can can
they can make a horror movie with nobody
you've ever heard of with a director
you've never heard of
with a story that's never been been
established in the marketplace and and
you can still make those movies and they
can still make money at the box office
and horror movies defy all those rules
for whatever reason um
which is interesting the horror genre is
very specific about that if you come up
with a concept that's great and the
visual concept that goes along with it
and you know
figure out like a wildly creative way to
kill people and things like that then
then you can you can still
you can still get that stuff made so so
uh which is great for the horror
for the horror industry
everything but the outside of the
horror industry
operates on pre-awareness in a major way
i actually like that idea for a movie
that the house sitter and that the guy
goes in and starts reading these scripts
because he's bored he has all this time
he's supposed to stay there and then he
starts writing himself he doesn't take
anybody's ideas but he just starts he
says you know what i want to do a
screenplay and he gets made i love it
that would be that would be awesome yeah
you should write that okay
maybe i don't know
just establish it check with your
friends
you